(audience cheering)
- Please welcome the one,
the only, Pete Holmes.
- Hi. Hello, Pete.
(audience cheering wildly)
- Hello, hello, hello,
my hair is shorter, hello.
I got a haircut, hello.
- And you look good.
- Oh, Pete Holmes,
- Oh, thank you very much.
- love you so...
You guys look great.
- [Drew] Really? Hair and makeup.
- Really? I woke up
like this, so I'm good.
- [Pete] There you go.
(everybody laughing)
- Pete. I'm so excited
about this new show.
Your character, Tom, gets laid off
and becomes a professional bowler.
Tell us everything.
Also, do you hit turkeys?
Because I love (gobbling)
saying turkey when bowling,
and can you explain what a turkey is,
and tell us about the show?
- Oh my God.
You want me to explain,
a turkey is a, is a fowl.
It's a bird.
It's a delicious, dry meat,
(Ross laughing)
that you only get if you
hit three strikes in a row
in bowling, I believe.
- That's it.
- That's it, that's it, well done.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you very much.
- You got it. I'm impressed.
- Thank you, thank you very much.
- Were you a bowler before this?
- Only, you know, we did
candlepin 'cause I'm from Boston.
That's, this is on the
show, we do ten-pin bowling.
- [Drew] Wait, what's candlepin?
- But candlepin is-
- Candlepin, please?
- It's like a hard cantaloupe
that you roll at smaller pins.
You can hold it in your hand.
- Is it a real melon?
(Pete laughing loudly)
- I know, I'm picturing full honeydew.
- Right? That's what I thought too.
- You know what?
- What?
- I'm gonna say yes, it is a real melon
because I want you living
the rest of your life
telling people that in
Boston, we bowl with fruit.
- With fruit.
(audience laughing)
- Yes, these balls that
we used on the show,
and we used real balls,
they're like 10-pound balls
the ones that you put
your fingers in and roll.
- Yeah.
- 10-pound balls.
- Drew, stop right now.
(audience chuckling)
- Drew, you would've been
a real fit on the set
'cause we couldn't stop.
Everybody would say, "Somebody
get Pete his ball bag."
"Where's Pete's ball bag?"
(Drew laughing)
- [Ross] Oh my God.
- [Pete] This is my kind of show.
(Ross laughing)
- Welcome home.
- And you are our kind of guy, Pete.
In fact, will you hit
some headlines with us?
- [Pete] I will.
- All right, thank God,
(audience cheering)
'cause we always need your take on things.
- [Ross] All right.
- Ross, your story.
- Up first, we've got a biggie
when it comes to relationships.
Here's a question.
How soon is too soon to say "I love you"?
- [Drew] Ooh.
- I know.
Well+Good talk to relationship experts
who put an actual number on it.
They say you should wait
until at least three months
- [Audience Members] Yes.
- before you say it.
- Oh, the audience agrees. They do.
They say three to five
months is the ideal window
for saying, I love you.
And it works the other way too.
If you're not feeling it by five months,
then Houston we may have a problem.
I think there is no too soon.
It's just like, don't
say it first, because...
(audience laughing)
Right?
There's such risk in that.
- That is hilarious.
- Oh God, I don't, that
makes me so uncomfortable.
I love you.
Anything?
(audience chuckling)
- So you won't say it first Rossi?
- I didn't say it first, no.
Welly said it first to me.
- Have you ever said it first to anyone?
- No.
(audience laughing)
- Ross, let's do a trust
exercise right now.
Say it to me. I promise. I got you.
- I love you, Pete.
(everybody laughing)
- I love you too, Ross.
- Oh, it works! It works!
(audience clapping)
Well, he meant it.
- But, it's like a trust ball.
It's like a trust ball.
You just gotta do it once.
By the way, three months,
These are the same people
saying to go to bed at 9:39.
These are made up things.
- Thank you.
- Right?
- Thank you,
in fact, is an Uber rating arbitrary?
Pete, do you have your Uber rating?
- I did.
I looked it up when you
guys were looking yours up.
- Give it up.
- Okay,
and I just got Drew's by the way.
I do, I have yours.
- Oh God, oh no.
- What's yours first, Pete?
- 4.73. Is that good?
- This is very good.
(audience cheering)
- Okay.
- It's not a 4.89,
but it's good.
(audience clapping)
- Ross has a better rating,
but he's more intimidating
about saying I love you.
See, these are what all,
all of us humans are-
- Well, that's my problem.
I get in the Uber and I go, I
love you with my whole heart.
And I'm probably freaking
some of these people out.
(everybody laughing)
- Listen, I will say we
have good Uber ratings
and Drew Barrymore,
yours is really good too.
It's not as good as ours.
(audience laughing)
4.68.
- I'm so mad.
- You are the nicest person I've ever met
but I bet you it's the late, the running-
- It's the late, it's
that I keep them waiting.
Gah! All right. You know what?
Here's a goal.
I'm gonna get that Uber rating up.
- [Ross] That is a
challenge you can do, Drew.
(audience clapping)
- And we're gonna ask Jimmy
Fallon his Uber rating.
All right, next story.
We're talking potty pastimes, oh.
We've checked about checking
your phone on the toilet.
Apparently most people do use
their phone on the toilet.
This is a thing,
- Fine with it,
but it turns out there might be
a snacking on the toilet thing happening.
(audience gasping loudly)
I know, Metro reports a new
poll found 18% of adults
said that they've had a
nibble while they dribble.
- [Ross] No, stop it.
- Yes. Actually one or
number two was not specified,
- God.
- So let's just say one in six people
admit to snacking on the bowl.
Okay.
(Drew laughing)
Ross, don't ask.
- Oh my God.
- No, don't even ask me.
I do not. I do-
Where do the crumbs go?
(audience laughing)
- You just open your
legs just a little bit,
- No.
- it goes straight down.
- Yes, (indistinct)
(audience laughing)
- You do the same thing on the couch.
Just brush 'em off.
- Yeah, straight down.
- Tell me you don't eat on the toilet.
- I'm on the toilet right now.
(everybody laughing)
- Well, Pete Holmes, we love you so much.
Will you please come
back as soon as possible
so we can talk more
- Oh, yes, please.
- about "How We Roll" which
premieres tonight, everybody,
at 9:30,
- Please watch.
(audience cheering wildly)
- Eastern, on CBS.
Oh, Pete Holmes, I love you so much.
- I love you guys.
- I love you.
- I love you, Ross, don't forget.
(upbeat music)